Her world.
It's Saroj and we're going to make an a
half that reads an article of texts and
creates a one sentence summary out of it.
Using the power of natural
language processing language
is in many ways the seat
of intelligence.
It's the original communication protocol
that we invented to describe all the
incredibly complex processes
happening in our neocortex.
Do you ever feel like you're getting
flooded with an increasing amount of
articles and links and videos to
choose from as this data grows,
the importance of semantic
entity does as well.
How can you say the most important
things in the shortest amount of time?
Having a generated summary lets you decide
whether you want to deep dive further
or not and the better it gets,
the more we'll be able to apply it to
more complex language like that in a
scientific paper for even an entire book.
The future of NLP is a very bright
one. Interestingly enough, no.
One of the earliest use cases for
machine summarization was by the Canadian
government in the early nineties for a
weather system they invented called fog.
Instead of sifting through
all the meteorological data,
they had access to manually,
they led fog,
read it and generate a weather
forecast from it on a recurring basis.
It had a set textual template and it
would fill in the values for the current
weather. Given the data, something
like this, it was just an experiment,
but they found that sometimes people
actually prefer the computer generated
forecasts to the human ones,
partly because the generated one's
used more consistent terminology.
A similar approach has been applied in
fields with lots of data that needs human
readable summaries like
finance and in medicine.
Summarizing a patient's medical data has
proven to be a great decision support
tool for doctors. Most summarization
tools in the past or extractive,
they selected unexisting subset of words
or numbers from some data to create a
summary. What you and I do, something
a little more complex than that.
When we summarize,
our brain builds an internal semantic
representation of what we've just read.
And from that we can generate a summary.
This is instead an abstract of method
and we can do this with deep learning.
What can't we do with it?
So let's build a tech summarizer that
can generate a headline from a short
article using care Os.
We're going to use this collection of
news articles as our training data.
We'll convert it to pickle format,
which essentially means converting
it into a raw bytes stream.
Pickling is a way of converting a python
object into a character stream so we
can easily reconstruct that
object in another python script.
Modularity for the wind,
we're saving the data as a tool with
the heading description and keywords.
The heading and description or the
list of headings and their respective
articles in order and the keywords are
akin to tags, but we won't be using those.
In this example,
we're going to first tokenize or split
up the text into individual words because
that's the level we're going to deal with.
This data in our headline will
be generated one word at a time.
We want some way of
representing words numerically.
Angio coined a term for this called word
embeddings back in 2003 but they were
first made popular by a team
of researchers at Google
when they were least word
to Vec inspired by boys.
To men. Just kidding.
Word to Vec is a two layer neural net
trained on a big label text corpus.
It's a pre trained model you can download.
It takes a word as its input and
produces a vector as it's output.
One vector per word. Creating word vectors
lets us analyze words mathematically.
So these high dimensional
vectors represent words and
each dimension in codes a
different property like gender or title.
The magnitude along each access represents
the relevance of that property to a
word. So we could say king plus
men minus woman equals queen.
We can also find the similarity between
words, which equates to distance.
Word to VEC offers a predictive
approach to creating word vectors,
but another approach is count based
and the popular algorithm for that.
His glove short for global vectors.
If first constructs a large co-occurrence
matrix of words by context for each
word I he row, it'll count how
frequently it sees it in some contexts,
which is the column.
Since the number of contexts can be large,
it factorized is the matrix to
get a lower dimensional matrix,
which represents words by features.
So each row has a feature representation
for each word and they also traded on a
large text corpus.
Both performed similarly well
by glove trains a little faster.
So we'll go with that.
We'll download the pretrained glove word
vectors from this link and save them to
disk. Then we'll use them to initialize
and embedding matrix with our tokenize
vocabulary from our training data.
We'll initialize it with random numbers
and copy all the glove weights of words
show up in our training vocabulary and
for every word outside this embedding
matrix will find the closest word inside
the Matrix by measuring the coastline
distance of glove vectors.
Now we've got this matrix of word
embeddings that we could do so many things
with.
So how are we going to use these word
embeddings to create a summary headline
for a novel article? We feed it.
Let's back up for a second, Ben.
A squad first introduce a
neural architecture called
sequence to sequence in
2014 at later inspired the Google brain
team to use it for text summarization
successfully.
It's called sequence to sequence because
we are taking an input sequence and al
putting not a single value,
but a sequence as well.
We're going to end code. Then
we be code. We join it in code.
Then we z code went up.
He did a book.
It gets back to rise and
when I decode that as Mariah,
so we use two recurrent networks,
one for each sequence.
The first is the encoder network.
It takes an input sequence and creates
an encoded representation of it.
The second is the decoder network.
We feed it as its input,
that same encoded representation and
it will generate an output sequence by
decoding it. There are different ways
we could approach this architecture.
One approach would be to
let encoder network learn
needs in bedding from scratch
by feeding in our training data,
but we're taking a less computationally
expensive approach because we already
have learned embeddings from glove.
When we build our encoder LSTM network,
we'll set those pretrained embeddings
as our first layers weights.
The embedding layer is meant to turn
input integers into fixed size vectors.
Anyway,
we've just given it a huge headstart.
By doing this and when
we train this model,
it will just find tune or improve the
accuracy of our embeddings as a supervised
classification problem where the input
data is our set of vocab words and the
labels are there
associated headline words.
We'll minimize the cross entropy loss
using rms prop. Now for our decoder,
our decoder will generate headlines.
It will have the same LSTM architecture
as our encoder and we'll initialize its
weights using our same
pretrained glove embeddings.
It will take as input
the vector representation
generated after feeding in the
last word of the input text,
so it will first generate
its own representation using
it's embedding layer and
the next step is to convert
this representation into a word,
but there is actually one more step.
We need a way to decide what part of
the input we need to remember like names
and numbers.
We talked about the importance of memory.
That's why we use LSTM cells,
but another important aspect of
learning theory is attention.
Basically what is the most
relevant data to memorize?
Our decoder will generate
a word as it's output.
And that same word will be fed in as
input when generating the next word,
until we have a headline,
we use an attention mechanism.
When out putting each word in
the decoder for each output word,
it computes a weight over each of the
input words that determines how much
attention should be
paid to that input word.
All the weights some up to one and are
used to compute a weighted average of the
last hidden layers generated. After
processing each of the input at words,
we'll take that weighted average and
input it into the softmax layer along with
the last hidden layer from the
current step of the decoder.
So let's see what our model generates for
this article after training. All right,
we've got this headline
generated beautifully,
and let's do it once more
for a different article.
Couldn't have said it better myself.
So to break it down,
we can use retrained word vectors using
a model like love easily to avoid having
to create them ourselves to generate an
output sequence of words given an input
sequence of words. We use a neural
encoder decoder architecture,
and by adding an attention
mechanism to our decoder,
it can help it decide what is the
most relevant token to focus on when
generating new texts.
The winner of the coding challenge
from the last video is just soon.
See he wrote an AI composer
in 100 lines of code.
Last week's challenge was non trivial
and he managed to get a working demo up.
So definitely check out his
repo wizard of the week.
The coding challenge for this video is
to use a sequence to sequence model with
care os to summarize a piece of text
posts or get hub link in the comments and
I'll announce the winner.
Next video,
please subscribe for
more programming videos.
And for now I've got to remember to
pay attention. So thanks for watching.